patrick bourdillon bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france on le disait
manifestation donc aujourd'hui à l'appel
de l'intersyndicale cgt fo dans les
services de réanimation
alors quelles sont les différentes
revendications essentiellement des
revendications suite à ce qu'on a pu
voir qu'il est fier du coc vide vous en
doutez c'est les revendications en
matière de conditions de travail au
maintien d'un niveau d'encadrement des
patients dans le service de réanimation
qui sont extrêmement sollicités ces
derniers temps et en matière de
rémunérations pour laquelle en tout cas
monsieur macro qui avait fait des
promesses via son ministre des
solidarités la santé n'y a pour
l'instant pas tenu alors parce qu'il ya
un an finalement on entendait les mêmes
revendications souvient qu est ce que ça
veut dire c'est à dire qu absolument
rien n'a bougé depuis un an on ne peut
pas dire que rien n'a bougé puisqu'on a
vu que la pression en tout cas delarue
est ce qu'on a pu organiser comme
journée d'action qu'ils ont été
relativement forte
sas a eu un impact a été un impact assez
insuffisant on va dire puis celle de
ségur la santé et à un certain nombre
d'avancées notamment en matière de
réflexion sur les rémunérations
essentiellement des personnels
infirmiers mais je vous rappelle qu'un
ranimation n'y a pas que des personnels
infirmiers et aussi les personnes à
l'aide soignant et à des personnels
techniques et des personnels
administratifs des personnels médicaux
et les personnels en interne
donc les questions qui se posent en tout
cas et qui reviennent de façon
récurrente ce qui a eu des promesses de
la part du gouvernement en matière de
rémunérations qui n'ont pas été tenues
notamment ceux des révisions de grille
de salaires qui concerne l'ensemble des
professions hospitalière mais surtout il
ya eu une promesse qui a été fait par le
président de la république et par le
ministre solidarité la santé en juillet
de l'année dernière qui était
l'ouverture de lits pérenne de
réanimation et on a pu constater en tout
cas la vague qui est en train de
s'estomper
je dirais plutôt de s'amenuiser en ce
moment en fait la démonstration qu'en
tout cas cette promesse n'a pas été
tenue
est ce que nous en réclamer qu'on
demande très fortement à ce gouvernement
c'est d'avoir et c'est l'objet de
une action aujourd'hui dans leur
animation c'est d'avoir un niveau
d'encadrement des patients qui est un
niveau qui préfectoral ise avec des taux
qui sont des taux connus qui sont des
tours nationaux mais qui correspondent
au nombre de vies qui existe dans les
animations et non pas au nombre de
patients qui les écoutent
c'est à dire qu'il ya besoin d'effectifs
ils sont effectifs formés sont effectifs
en capacité de pouvoir répondre aux
sollicitations qui sont les
sollicitations extrêmement forte dans un
contexte qui est évidemment pour une
délétère dans lequel le gouvernement
maintient sa position notamment en
matière de fermetures de service
réanimation dans les hôpitaux de
proximité
donc on est dans une démarche où ses
services appel à l'action aujourd'hui et
nous appelons à l'action aujourd'hui
dans ses services dans une perspective
plus générale dans les hôpitaux qui est
celle de la journée d'action du 15
juillet sur laquelle façon très
transversal c'est l'ensemble du monde
hospitalier de l'action sociale et du
médico social qui sera dans la rue pour
demander au gouvernement des moyens
alors concernant la situation par les
services de réanimation
vous le disiez une baisse de la tension
depuis quelques jours un gouvernement on
le disait là encore qui lui se montre
plutôt optimiste qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous qu est ce que vous observez
au quotidien ces dernières heures ces
dernières jours dans dans les hôpitaux
dans les services de réanimation
notamment est ce que nous observons
c'est un frémissement en termes de
baisse puisqu'elle a baissé très
disparates d'une région à l'autre et les
régions effectivement la situation est
devenue quasiment normal mais des
régions a notamment si je pense à la
région parisienne on est dans des
situations qui est encore assez
explosive les taux d'occupation qui sont
relativement élevés donc les vraies
questions qui se posent c'est à savoir à
nouveau de quelle façon à ce qu'on a
réussi par par des bouts de ficelle par
des subterfuges par désorganiser les
établissements hospitaliers je vous
rappelle que le coc vide n'est pas la
seule pathologie que nos hôpitaux sont
censés traiter les autres pathologies
continue à courir et à partir de là il
faut se poser les vraies questions
savoir ce que notre système sanitaire
répond nécessité la population en tout
cas nous ce qu'on peut observer
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
c'est que les poissons c'est toujours
pas le cas et que si légère décrue ciel
et gerber s en matière de niveaux de
spécialisation notamment de
animation certes ce n'est pas le cas en
matière d'hospitalisation 20 des soins
continus qui sont aussi des lieux sur
lequel la pression est extrêmement forte
et sur lequel il ya des nécessités
d'avoir y compris des réorganisations
mais surtout d'avoir des effectifs
supplémentaires et dans nos services qui
sont desservis d'aval puisque je vous
rappelle qu'un patient qui sort de
réanimation c'est un patient aussi qui a
besoin d'une continuité en matière
d'hospitalisation et de prise en charge
notamment par le service qui sont des
services de soins de suite et de
rééducation pour lesquels on peut
constater par exemple sur les hôpitaux
parisiens
martin hirsch a décidé la fermeture de
certains moments de liker conséquent
donc on est sur une désorganisation
complète du système de santé dans un
système où on pallie pour l'instant à
l'urgence on est arrivé de bric et de
broc à et s'il ne s'en sortir et essayer
d'avoir le moins de casse possible mais
la réalité c'est que dans la durée de la
politique est engagé qu'une politique de
réduction de l'offre de l'organisation
de soins cette politique sera délétère
vague d'ici quelques mois quelques
années nous avons peur nous savoir ce
qui va se passer l'hiver prochain quand
la grippe saisonnière va réapparaître
quand le coville va se réactiver
puisqu'on sait que ce virus qui aime
bien le froid nous avons chlore de la
suite nous l'avions déjà dit pour la bac
qui vient de se passer maintenant
et on s'aperçoit que ce sont les
personnels qui ont été mis à
contribution un très fortement mais
surtout ils ont ils sont à un niveau de
tension qui fait que maintenant ils ne
supporteront pas je le dis très
clairement une quatrième bague qui
serait une bande violente mais celles ci
n'ont effectivement pas ce qu on entend
aussi parler de burnout un parmi les
personnels hospitaliers est ce que vous
constatez des arrêts de travail en
hausse par exemple est ce que ces
personnes qui sont absentes à ce
qu'elles sont remplacés dont le livre
d'harry travail oui et en os mais au
delà de simples arrêt de travail
on est surtout dans des logiques au
beaucoup de professionnels s'interrogent
même sur leur présence dans nos
établissements hospitaliers et
s'interroge surtout sur la valeur de ce
qu'on peut avoir comme travail de ce
qu'on reconnaît dans sa propre capacité
à pouvoir gérer les situations d'urgence
et surtout avant la volonté de rester
dans les établissements on va avoir
affaire ans a déjà démarré à une
hémorragie de professionnels qui vont
quitter les établissements parce qu'il
ne supporte plus la situation et que
nous en sommes à 18 mois pour l'instant
d'une pression qui est extrêmement forte
et au delà des services d urgence et
tout le monde hospitalier qui
sous pression parce que ce soit les
personnels administratifs au personnel
soignant des services dits tiède ou que
ce soit des personnels techniques la
pression est extrêmement fort depuis 18
mois dont l'interrogation qui se pose
actuellement c'est y compris sur le
niveau de recrutement notamment sur des
personnels jeunes diplômés qui vont
arriver les prochains mois sur le marché
du travail sur lequel on s'aperçoit que
nos établissements n'arrive plus à
recruter parce que personne ne veut
venir bosser à l'hôpital mais au clair
et interrogations c'est celle-là est et
comment est ce que vous vous expliquer
que les autorités n'entendent pas vos
alertes finalement très régulière depuis
ces dernières années
vous avez fait allusion d'un dividende
hiver de vos reportages sur l'élément
central
l'élément central nous avons des
gouvernements ces dernières à nixon et
gouvernement plus attachés à la logique
financière que la logique humaine
la question qui va se poser et sur
laquelle effectivement il ya une
pression qui est mise de façon très
claire sur les prochaines semaines et
les prochains mois
c'est que va devenir le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et à
quel niveau va-t-il permettre de
financer nos établissements à hauteur de
nécessité le gouvernement est plus
attaché à la résolution de problèmes
budgétaires car la résolution de
nécessité de la population je le dis
très vertement de cette façon là pascal
moment ce qu'on peut constater qu'en
tout cas dans ce qui va être proposé
dans les prochains mois c'est de façon
très claire le gouvernement n'a pas tiré
les leçons en matière de santé publique
de ce qu'est la nécessité d'avoir un
hôpital public qu'ils soient construits
qui sont à proximité qui répondent aux
besoins
mais il a surtout lui un élément de
compréhension et bruno le maire a été
très clair le quoi qu'il en coûte se
transformer à comment est-ce qu'on
rembourse mais de façon très claire on
sait pertinemment que c'est la
protection sociale qui va en subir les
conséquences de plein fouet en premier
lieu donc ce sera une réponse économique
une logique qui pas la nôtre en tout cas
qui est logique sanitaire
merci beaucoup patrick bourdillon
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire général secrétaire fédéral
pardon cgt santé